[Music]
welcome everybody to low on crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber two women known for
their YouTube channels on parenting and
religion appeared in a Utah courtroom
for the very first time on Friday
they're both charged with felony child
abuse Ruby Frankie lives in Utah with
her husband and six children their
YouTube channel called Eight passengers
had more than 2 million subscribers
before it was taken down earlier this
year according to a probable cause
affidavit Frankie and her business
partner Jody Hildebrand were both
arrested last week Frankie's 12 year old
son had climbed out of a window at
hildebrandt's house and gone to a
neighbor he was emaciated with open
wounds and had duct tape on his wrists
and ankles Frankie's ten-year-old
daughter was found in very similar
conditions inside the home both children
were taken to the hospital while the
other four children were placed in the
care of Utah's Division of Child and
Family Services both Frankie and
Hildebrandt are facing six counts of
felony child abuse there have been
reports over the years that Frankie
might be abusing her children based on
what viewers saw in her videos but it
seems nothing came of these reports
until now Frankie often collaborated
with Hildebrand on parenting and child
care videos YouTube confirmed that it
shut down two channels associated with
Frankie during Friday's hearing we
learned that Frankie and Hildebrandt
will both be held without bail for now a
bail hearing is scheduled for a few
weeks from now so let's talk about it
with my co-hosts my legal analyst Terry
Austin Brian buckmeyer good to see you
both Terry I'm going to start with you
state has like a lot of video evidence
in this case how do you think that's
going to play a factor well I think what
the defendants are going to claim is
look you have good video you have bad
video you see as we just saw the
children happy and they are playing and
they are healthy so I think the videos
can cut both ways I think they're also
going to say no one was harmed now
clearly we know that the young boy did
have cuts and bruises but for the most
part I think that they're going to try
to say that there wasn't any serious
bodily harm they've been charged with as
we know you know this abuse and it's a
felony under Utah law and it's a serious
felony it's a second degree felony so I
think that they're going to try to say
look there wasn't that serious bodily
harm we didn't abuse them we thought
that under our faith this is what we're
supposed to do I don't think these
defenses are going to hold up but I
think that's what they're going to the
way that I read it that she's charged
you know six charges and with respect to
just to give you one that the young boy
it could either be torture it could be
starvation it could be emotional a
developmental harm so it's kind of broad
about what child's abuse could mean here
with respect to the injuries walk me
through the bail the bond issue there
any chance she could get out before
trial I think it's more of a question as
to what their finances are I think this
is again horrible horrible case but it's
not a homicide case we're typically used
to those murder cases where they're
remanded no amount of bond or Bill will
get them out I think that there will be
some amount of bond or bailing the
strongest arguments the defense would
have is she can't see her children She's
accused of abusing her children she'll
never be able to repeat this charge
again the court can issue restraining
orders which you cannot speak to or
reach out to her children of course
they're out of her custody I would
imagine a very high amount of bail or
Bond the question is whether or not
they'll be able to make it I think there
are some arguments there for the defense
but for the prosecution the arguments to
keep her in are very strong the idea of
the level of the crime and the strength
of the case I think this is an easily
provable case based on what you just
said the broadness of what abuse is in
this case if it's not the injuries that
we heard in the nylon one call or what
we're going to likely hear from the
medical reports is just the emotional
effect that it's going to have on these
children I'm thinking we're going to
hear from social workers who interview
these children afterwards and hear wow
these are not healthy normal children as
we expect them to be in the state of
Utah this is something that has happened
to these children over a long period of
time and they're really emotionally
damaged and she can't say she didn't
know what was happening because my
understanding is she filmed a YouTube
video in that house with like two days
prior when the children were there oh
that's right she knew what was going on
they collaborated and did the same thing
to the children that's the allegation
we're going to talk more about about it
because still ahead on Long crime daily
there is lots more to talk about in this
case and we got our hands on the 911
phone call that a neighbor made when one
of Frankie's emaciated children showed
up on his doorstep stay with us
[Music]
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody our coverage of the YouTube
mom charged with child abuse continues
now as we hear the 9-1-1 phone call that
first alerted police to the most recent
allegations against her correspondent
Sierra Gillespie has all the details
this kid is obviously been
I think he's been
he's been detained he's done
he's obviously covered in wounds we're
taking a closer look at the case of Ruby
Frankie the YouTuber mom now accused of
child abuse
first time we're hearing the chilling
9-1-1 call and emergency radio
communications after Frankie's son
escaped from her business partner's home
and was found emaciated with open wounds
he asked us to call the police
foreign
that 9-1-1 call came in just before 11
A.M on August 30th a neighbor in Ivins
Utah a remote area about four hours
south of Salt Lake City reported a 12
year old boy showed up at his house
asking for help I'm on the address of
your emergency tell me exactly what's
happened I just had a 12 year old boy
show up here at my front door asking for
help the caller then references problems
that the neighbor's home before
explaining the boy arrived looking
emaciated with duct tape around his
wrists and ankles
we know there's been problems at this
neighbor's house he's emaciated he's got
tape around his legs he's hungry and
he's thirsty officials later determined
the boy's mother is Ruby Frankie the
YouTuber behind the eight passengers
Channel Once boasting more than 2
million subscribers the channel is now
defunct after being terminated my gosh
you guys having kids is so much fun on
her YouTube channel Frankie documented
the lives of her six children and
husband Kevin recording videos about
everything from home renovations to back
to school shopping but Frankie's strict
mothering tactics came under Fire long
before her arrest and my kids are
literally starving I hesitate to say
this because it's going to sound like
I'm like a mean Barbarian but I told the
kids I said I'm not even gonna let you
eat breakfast until you get your chores
done in the past Frankie had addressed
critics saying she wouldn't stop
mothering her way online who hate me
who would like to cancel me who would
like to see me
um either burn in hell as I have told or
disappear off the face of the Earth and
I'm not going anywhere First Responders
also mentioned Jody Hildebrand whose
home Frankie's son escaped from Frankie
and Hildebrand have a past relationship
collaborating on parenting videos
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie hmm let's talk about
that now on phone call Brian I have to
imagine if there's a trial that's coming
in there how bad is that for the defense
oh Jesse it's not just the playing of
the 901 call it's the fact that to get
it into evidence you'll probably get the
man on that phone describing what did
you see what did you feel why did you
use the word uh uh hunger or or duct
tape or like all of that what made you
think that this was going on that this
child was being starved and I can only
imagine and I can kind of hear it in the
man's voice as a kind of unsteady maybe
he's a father maybe he's thinking this
child came to me maybe there's a sense
of guilt we he said we've had problems
with these people in the past the way
that that witness will describe that
9-1-1 call I think if it is not the nail
in the coffin it is definitely one of
many that could be in this case and
usually they start these cases with the
dime one phone call on that person
um Terry a lot of people were critical
of her for a long time people were
suspecting there was abuse I think about
the Department of Child and Family
Services and I think about whether or
not they're going to have a role would
they be held legally responsible at all
what do you think I think the answer is
yes I mean the good news is these
children survived often
often where they're not rescued in time
and they don't survive here they survive
so I think that's working in favor of
the department but you see as we just
heard from Brian the desperation of this
neighbor on that 9-1-1 call he is saying
the children are emaciated this has been
going on for a long time people have
complained the thing I don't understand
Jesse is they canceled the show why
didn't at that point in time the
department come in and say something is
going on here it was enough for the
network to notice why not for the
Department to notice as well and so I do
think there could be a claim against
them the claim that all these people
have complained and if they had
intervened sooner perhaps that these you
know abuse accusations could not be made
because they would have saved them
beforehand so I think there's a
possibility you know what I take away
from it too is that RF this is the young
boy this is the initials that he went by
in the affidavit knew enough to know
this was wrong you know because
sometimes we see in these cases is the
children are manipulated they don't
realize what it's wrong enough to run to
a neighbor for help and and ask that you
know he's starving he's hungry he's
thirsty and to call authorities I think
that's a significant point